you know this is the beauty of french
cooking when you do it classically
that's when you take the bone that's
when you brown it that when you do a
reduction that's when you do all of that
and serve it remember you do that with
the beef the mezzo process is the oldest
cultural center on an American campus it
was built in nineteen thirteen to over a
hundred years old at this point and we
offer a variety of events and activities
around french and francophone culture
and history and by building this new
kitchen it's the last phase of a
renovation we are able to add to our
educational activities events focused on
food and cooking on cue maneri history
and tradition so we're inaugurating our
new kitchen with French chef Jacques
paypal who is here and going to be doing
a cooking demonstration of a few recipes
from one of his cookbooks called
essential paypal I moved my knife in a
kind of jig so fashion you know and my
knife is not original tile is not a
perpendicular or a no that is about 45
degree to Jacques and his book in his
autobiography mentions that when he was
here at Columbia many years ago the idea
of incorporating food into an academic
discipline was absolutely forbidden
nobody would buy it you could treat food
seriously as a subject of history of
literature or just treated as a subject
in and of itself that really mattered
I've been on that campus so many year
from 1951 to 1972 so at that time in
general 30 I did a BA and not really i
did a master in literature 18th century
and i proposed as my doctoral
dissertation and history of french food
starring in the 16th century with the
play at poet also another up to post
early 20th century and they will get
missing are you crazy food so it won't
really the world does challenge to have
certainty the world of cooking I mean 34
years ago any good mother with a morir
their child to Maria a lawyer a doctor
an architect satiny daughter cook now we
are genius
it goes so across his leg and makes a
map here there's a lot of interest in
food and cooking in the United States
and in France to build educational
activities around food and cooking that
would be open to students on campus but
also to the broader public coming from
New York and so we're really marking
here that the midst of all says I think
not just a wonderful evening with
Jacques repair but a whole
transformation in our way of thinking
about food and human relation to it but
I mean look at the stuffing that I did
had a bit of bread and a couple of slice
of cheese and a piece of I'm you know if
I would have finished sometime I do it
with finished oh they achieve